we've seen a lot of people rushing into
corporate bonds as everybody in the
world tries to get some sort of yield
here is that a smart move at this point
are people taking too much of a risk
using it maybe as a proxy for sovereigns
well Mike you know it's a quick formula
you you figure out what the spread is
let's let's take high yield at four
hundred and fifty basis points you
figure out what the annualized defaults
will be in the Recovery's let's say 4%
with a recovery of you know 50% and so
that takes two points off the four and a
half that leaves you two and a half
percent your relative to your Treasuries
yeah that's not a bad deal but it's not
the deal that investors think they're
going to get and if we have problems
elsewhere like we've been talking about
then certainly those spreads are going
to widen out i i think it's obvious that
when interest rates are at zero or
negative that that everything's tied
together you know the thigh bone and the
knee bone and the hip bone and jump
bonds and stocks and negative interest
bonds we're all tied together in some
way and so you must assume i think that
that the high-yield bond area is
artificially priced and at risk under
certain circumstances i wouldn't buy
them well effectively
matter of fact go ahead matter of fact
I'm short then I'm short them across all
categories of corporate or just
high-yield
no you know there are CDX which is a an
index of high-yield bonds and an IG CDX
which is an index of investment grade
bonds and you know those are derivatives
that are easily traded the IG CDX trades
at about 80 basis points the high-yield
you know basically at about 425 and so
yes when you when you buy protection as
opposed to sell protection which I've
done that's the same as shorting then
you're giving up that carry but you're
you're looking for a widening of spreads
and I think ultimately that's what
happens in both of those markets